[Music]
foreign
a first look at what is on the front
pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with the political editors of
the guardian and the song papakura and
Harry Cole welcome to both of you with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's check out the front pages then
shall we starting with the I which leads
with the grave warning at cop 27 from
the un's Secretary General that the
planet is on a highway to climate hell
The Daily Mail focuses on climate
activists demanding the UK should pay a
trillion pounds in Damages to poorer
countries affected by climate change
with the headline just what planet are
they on
the Metro remarks on the warm Rapport
between Rishi sunek and Emmanuel macron
at the summit after Mr sunac's
predecessor Liz truss cast out on
whether the French president was an ally
while the telegraph says a major gas
deal with the United States is set to
ease Britain's energy crisis
alongside reporting from cop Pippa has a
story in the guardian with allegations
that the cabinet office Minister and
former Defense secretary sir Gavin
Williamson told a senior civil servant
to Slit their throat so Gavin denies the
claims the financial times understands
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt will use his
Autumn statement to announce a hike in
inheritance tags to try to plug the 34
billion pound black hole in public
finances well the times it says benefits
and pensions will rise only in line with
inflation apparently breaking the pledge
to stick with the government's triple
lock
the express carries the prime minister's
pledge to get a grip on the migrant
crisis
the mirror has an exclusive about a
Channel 4 documentary which it says will
show the dissection of the body of a
young mum who died of cancer
and the star has Den Barbara Windsor's
widower sharing font tributes
yeah it's open season on Gavin
Williamson now the former Defense
secretary he was of course fired from
that job in very controversial
circumstances accused of leaking he was
then appointed education secretary in a
totally deal with Boris Johnson when he
came to power and it was fired for that
job for being useless so it was a
surprise to everyone when um when
Richard sunak brought him back everyone
suspected what was clearly quite obvious
was that Gavin Williamson had played
quite a key role in doing the numbers
for not only getting rid of Boris
Johnson but for installing Rishi sunak
second time lucky and was awarded with a
sort of non-made-up job in the cabinet
office but a right to attend cabinet
where it appears he doesn't actually
have a huge amount to do but I think
it's more about just keeping him in the
tent rather than rather than actually
giving everything to run which his track
record isn't been brilliant at so after
those bullying allegations emerged at
the at the weekend text messages sent a
former Chief whip which were aggressive
which was sweary which were which he's
doing like himself I said are around
Pleasant now lots more I suspect stories
we're going to see people coming out of
the woodwork saying well actually when
he was ex he did this to me and when
when I was white he did this as X so
pippa's got a very good example of this
uh when he was defense secretary he was
alleged he denies it but Legend said
some pretty foul things to a civil
servant now someone said to me this
morning when they read those text
messages over the weekend they thought
that Gavin had mellowed and somewhat in
his older age and actually they wouldn't
they weren't surprised that there were
lots of sort of very aggressive things
he said to people being circulated you
know some of this was in the public
domain as well back in back when he was
arguing as the treasury arguing it's
Downing streets
um for further defense Rises when he was
in his job he ran an extraordinarily
aggressive campaign for uh for more
money for the mod one that actually made
Theresa May quite uncomfortable and
wasn't ultimately that successful
because you know as someone once said
you can't just can't negotiate with
someone with that extreme so no surprise
now to see lots more allegations
starting to surface and it's become a
real problem for us doing that because
he's still on the steps of Downing
Street what 10 days ago and said I will
run a government of integrity at every
level we now know that he knew about
these this allegation that we made
against and not perhaps the full details
but the allegation before he appointed
Gavin Williamson and you wonder how long
he's gonna you know this new government
is going to allow it to be bogged down
with such lurid claims on the front of
the Guardian today yes I'm intrigued by
you saying that he delivered
um you know key numbers uh in the
departure of Boris Johnson and the
enthronement if I can put it that way of
Rishi soon I will come back to that in a
minute and also the idea that is it the
job of the chief whip to be threatening
and is he so well schooled in the dark
arts that he can't give it up even when
when the job is passed him by but anyway
the allegations in your paper then um
Pippa do pick up your story
I'm sorry about that my Wi-Fi connection
was was misbehaving yes so I was told um
by a senior civil servant that worked at
the ministry of Defense when Gavin
Williams son was defense secretary that
uh they that he conducted what the civil
servant described as a sustained
bullying campaign and there was a couple
of examples which really stood out to me
of allegations one which Gavin
Williamson allegedly told this
individual to Slit their throat and
another one when the then defense
secretary allegedly told uh this white
tall official to jump out of the window
um but I understand of other examples as
well and this was uh these both these
comments were made in front of other
civil servants in a meeting
um and I'm told by this white or lead
that they reported the behavior
unofficially to the mod's head of HR but
decided not to put in an official
Complaint but nevertheless took
contemporaneous notes so
um as Harry I think has been telling you
uh Gavin Williamson is in a difficult
position anyway with with other
allegations
um that have been that's been made about
his behavior and I think what this one
does in the front of Guardians the
guardian today is suggests that it was
you know it was more widespread it
raises further questions about Rishi
sinak's judgment and appointing into a
role that means he attends cabinet uh
when some of his behavior is you know
questionable at best and and actually
really quite outrageous at worst I
should say that he denies
um the allegation of bullying
um but uh my understanding is that the
there is no denial of the The Words
which we're creating in the guardian The
Words which he allegedly used uh he just
I understand uh doesn't feel that the
the uh could be described as bullying
Behavior yes absolutely a strong denial
certainly from uh sir Gavin Williamson
who said he strongly rejected uh this
allegation and have enjoyed good working
relationships with the many brilliant
officials I have worked with across
government so as you say no specific
allegations have ever he said been
brought to my attention but um the focus
most certainly on him we'll keep an eye
on that in the meantime let's head to
news from Egypt uh the I Harry
um you know really strong words from the
UN Chief effectively we're heading
towards Doom with the accelerator down
but I just want to ask you how you felt
our you know two most recent oh I say
that I forgot about this trust in the
middle how dare I do that with the with
you who wrote about her anyway Boris
Johnson and Rishi cynic if I name them
that might be easier for me and how you
think they both fared and what impact
they might have made at The Summit
well what she said that's been Keen to
play up though he's so delightful
delighted and pleased that Boris Johnson
is there and it shows what a brilliant
world leader the UK is on the world
stage but you have to wonder whether he
would have actually you turned on going
to cop had his predecessor not decided
to as a guest of the Egyptian government
uh turn up and it very much was the
Boris show this morning
um he was
um speaking to the New York Times which
in itself is quite amusing given the um
sort of slightly uh hostile coverage the
UK the New York Times has of Britain
generally Boris Johnson's Premiership
brexit it runs his long long long pieces
you know endlessly talking down Britain
so it was quite amusing to see him
engaging with them like that but he did
um he's not he proved he's not going to
hold back as a as a former prime
minister you you just see he doesn't
think he's done yet he was there saying
I'm here as the spirit of Glasgow I'm
the one that's keeping the flame going
and then he actually tore in to to his
you know to his success is trust by
saying we shouldn't Frack up Britain or
you know be be drilling in our green and
pleasant land he had to go his old
newspaper the Telegraph and some of his
own aides who was you know against
against wind power just saying that you
know oil isn't the answer so he really
did plant a flag uh in Egypt today and
then Richie soon that came in looking a
little bit sheepish you know he has
slightly been dragged there he didn't
want to go he'd made a very early
decision in his Premiership not to uh
and he had this sort of awkward feeling
of you know sort of Britain yes well
represented but um you know definitely
to two sort of big players now sort of
Shadow Boxing Around a very small Summit
you know they're all locked in this nice
resort in Egypt so quite an unusual
situation to find um you know you could
understand perhaps you know if two
politicians from different parties you
know Tony Blair or Gordon Brown and then
and then their successors David Cameron
and the like both being at something but
it's very rare to see a man who was
prime minister just a matter of weeks
ago and his successor pretending they
all get and all like each other but
actually you know you and I both know
they want to take pins on each other
yeah but it's a big issue isn't it
that's the point I guess
um The Guardian leading on this story
um really quoting the uh Prime Minister
of Barbados effectively suggesting that
poorer countries are the real victims of
the climate crisis
um in more ways than one and just very
quickly because we're overrunning here
the Daily Mail just what planet are they
on the suggestion about reparations for
past fossil fuel use need to be paid
towards those who are now suffering this
idea of loss and damage uh one trillion
pounds is now the demand they suggest
from uh from one campaign organization
and this is a conversation which is
dominating the summit thus far about
where the Western industrialized nations
owed it to poor ones who are on the
receiving end obviously the worst impact
of climate change countries like
Pakistan and Bangladesh suffering from
flooding and extreme weather events and
whether the West is a responsibility to
uh to finance them to help equip them
better to deal with to deal with climate
change and number 10 uh said this
morning that they supported money to
developing countries to tackle climate
change but very much steered away from
the word reparations which which some
have described it as in which the male
obviously story is about I think I
suspect we're going to hear a lot more
of this in the days ahead yeah indeed so
lots more coverage on that to come also
in the next part of our program a
possible deal with the United States on
the horizon which could ease the energy
crisis here at home we will talk more
about that in just a moment
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me now paper Carrera and
Harry Cole from the guardian and the sun
respectively
um Harry let's go to the telegraph shall
we
um a gas deal set to ease our energy
crisis
um Rishi sunak the paper says poised to
announce a major gas deal with the US
after the cop 27 climate change crisis
you are smiling should we not be so
confident
no I think I think this this has been
ready to be announced um for some time
and I think it was due to be announced
the week that Liz trust resigned but um
obviously she never got around to it
this has been something that the the has
been reported then uh quite extensively
actually that they've been looking to uh
the UK has been looking to sign various
gas deals with other countries protect
against blackouts essentially by bulk
buying large amounts of gas at an
inflated price there was a similar
negotiations going on with Norway which
I think collapsed actually over the the
hype the the the the larger asking price
Norwegians were asking and the fact is
that the global gas prices are actually
falling so you don't want to get locked
in a situation where you buy loads of
gas now for a higher price now this I
understand has been going on since the
since the summer really when deem zahawi
the X Chancellor um the chance before
this current one I think no two chances
again
um flew out to the US and started
negotiating this deal in in the end of
August it was then discussed by Biden
and Truss it's around out their premise
you and it was actually I think ready to
go uh before her government all blew up
so um it's uh it's good to see we've
seen that getting some early wins for
his his hard yards he's putting in the
10 days so far yes and I'm glad you're
getting as confused as I am about how
many people have attention
and the rest of it anyway
um so just very quickly uh we go to the
metro and the express Pippa as soon act
turns on the charm is how the Metro
describes that meeting with the French
President uh but the Daily Express is
all wrapped into I will get a grip on
the migrant crisis has he taken over
this issue do you think
foreign
is that a final deal is uh is imminent
not announced today but we're expecting
it at some point soon it's the first
face-to-face meeting the two leaders
have had and of course the issue which
has dominated British politics or one of
several issues which dominated British
politics in the last couple of weeks is
the small boats and immigration uh uh
problem and how the government's going
to tackle with it Cenex Keen to get to
grips with it they need the French's
help with that in terms of patrolling on
French beaches I suspect we'll hear a
lot more about that uh when the details
are announced in the coming days